in this video we'll explore the complete
history of Ahsoka Tano one of the most
beloved characters in the Star Wars
Galaxy Ahsoka Tano is a force sensitive
to bruta female who is trained as a Jedi
Padawan by Anakin Skywalker during the
Clone Wars and later became a rebel
leader and a key figure in the fight
against the Galactic Empire she also
made her live-action debut in the second
season of The Mandalorian played by
Rosario Dawson Ahsoka was born on the
planet Chile in 36 BBY she was
discovered by Jedi Master plokun at the
age of three who sensed her strong
connection to the force and brought her
to the Jedi Temple on Coruscant there
she was raised and trained in the ways
of the Jedi Order learning how to wield
the lightsaber and use her force
abilities in 22 BBY when the Clone Wars
broke out between the Republic and the
separatists Ahsoka was assigned as a
Padawan to Anakin Skywalker by Jedi
Master Yoda she met her new Master on
the planet christopsis where they joined
forces with Obi-Wan Kenobi and his clone
troopers to break through the separatist
blockade Ahsoka proved herself to be a
brave and skilled fighter earning the
name Snips from Anakin for her snippy
attitude after christopsis Ahsoka and
Anakin were sent on a mission to rescue
Jabba the Hut's son Rada from a separate
space on teth they faced many challenges
along the way such as Droid attacks
bounty hunters and hostile Wildlife they
also discovered that Count Dooku was
behind the kidnapping and that he
planned to frame the Jedi for rata's
death Ahsoka and Anakin managed to
escape with Rada and deliver him back to
Jabba on Tatooine securing an alliance
with the Hutt Clan while on Tatooine
Ahsoka had her first encounter with
asajj of interests Dooku's Sith
apprentice and a deadly enemy of the
Jedi Ventress ambushed Ahsoka and
engaged her in a fierce lightsaber duel
Ahsoka held her own against Ventress but
was eventually overpowered and disarmed
she was saved by Anakin who arrived in
time to drive Ventress away for the next
three years Ahsoka fought alongside
Anakin in many battles across the Galaxy
such as Geonosis ryloth Felucia kamino
umbara and Kato nymodia she also formed
friendships with other Jedis such as
Obi-Wan Kenobi flokoon luminara unduli
Baris offy and Ayla Sakura she also
developed a bond with Captain Rex and
his clone troopers who respected her as
a leader and a comrade in 21 BBY Ahsoka
was part of a mission to investigate a
mysterious distress signal in the create
lithium system there she and her
companions encountered a strange planet
called mortis where they met three
powerful force wielders the Father the
Son and the daughter these beings
represented different aspects of the
force balance Darkness and Light they
tested Ahsoka and her friends in various
ways revealing their Destinies and
secrets ahsoko is briefly corrupted by
the sun's Dark Side influence but was
healed by the daughter's sacrifice she
also had a vision of her future self who
warned her about leaving Anakin later
Ahsoka joined Anakin and Obi-Wan on a
mission to rescue Jedi Master even peel
from a separatist prison on Lola sayu
they infiltrated The Citadel a heavily
fortified facility designed to hold Jedi
prisoners there they face many dangers
such as electrified walls race Shields
droids and traps they also met Captain
Tarkin a republic officer who had a
different view on the war than the Jedi
Ahsoka and Tarkin clashed over their
opinions on leadership and morality
despite their differences they were able
to work together to escape the Citadel
with peel and his Vital Information
Ahsoka continued to participate in many
more events during the Clone Wars
including the Battle of moncala where
she helped Prince leechar Unite is
people against the separatist Invaders
the mission to zigeria where she was
captured and enslaved by the zigerian
queen Mirage sintel but was freed by
Anakin and Obi-Wan the rescue of onderon
where she trained a group of rebels led
by Lux Von Terry a former separatist
Senator and her love interest to
overthrow the separatist puppet King
Sanjay rash the Gathering where she
accompanied six young Jedi initiates to
illum to find their kyber crystals for
their lightsabers and the mission to
Scipio where she protected padame
Amidala from an assassination attempt by
Rush Clovis a corrupt banker and padme's
ex-lover in 20 BBY ahsoka's life took a
dark turn when she was framed for a
bombing at the Jedi Temple and for the
murder of her friend to let it
determined she was hunted by the
Republic forces and the Jedi Council who
believed she was guilty she was helped
by Anakin and Captain Rex who tried to
prove her innocence she also encountered
a tsaj Ventress who had left the Sith
and became a bounty hunter Ventress
offered to help Ahsoka find the true
culprit but was betrayed by Baris offy
ahsoka's former friend and fellow
Padawan offie was revealed to be behind
the attacks as part of her plan to
expose the corruption of the Jedi and
the Republic Ahsoka was cleared of all
charges but was disillusioned by the the
Jedi's lack of trust in her she decided
to leave the order and walk away from
her life as a Jedi in the year 19 BBY
Ahsoka was contacted by Boca tan Crees a
Mandalorian warrior and the leader of
the night owls okatan asked Soka to help
her liberate Mandalore from Darth Maul
who had taken over the planet with a
shadow Collective Ahsoka agreed to join
bocatan's cause and reunited with Anakin
and Obi-Wan on Mandalore they gave her a
squad of Clone Troopers loyal to her led
by Captain Rex Ahsoka led the assault on
Maul's base in tsundari where she
confronted Maul in a fierce duel she
managed to capture Maul and expose his
plan to lure Anakin to the dark side
however before she could deliver mall to
Coruscant Order 66 was executed by
Chancellor Palpatine who revealed
himself as Darth Sidious the Sith Lord
behind the war ahsoka's clone troopers
turned against her following their
programming to kill all Jedi Ahsoka
escaped with Rex's help who'd removed
his inhibitor chip that controlled his
mind they faked their deaths and buried
their fallen comrades on a moon Ahsoka
also left behind one of her lightsabers
as a Decoy for Darth Vader after Order
66 Ahsoka went into hiding and adopted
the code name fulcrum she became an
informant and operative for bail
organa's Rebel Network which opposed the
Empire's tyranny she helped various
Rebel cells across the Galaxy such as
Harrison doulas ghost crew on lothal she
also encountered Darth Vader who was her
former Master Anakin corrupted by the
dark side she sensed a familiar presence
in him but didn't know his true identity
until later ahsoka's original
lightsabers had green blades but they
were later changed to Blue by Anakin as
a gift before the siege of Mandalore
Ahsoka used these blue lightsabers to
fight Darth Maul and his Mandalorian
loyalists but she had to abandon them
when she faked her death to escape the
clone troopers who turned on her when
she started to work under the code name
fulcrum she needed new weapons to
continue her fight against the empire so
she tracked down an imperial Inquisitor
a former Jedi who hunted down survivors
of order 66. she fought him and managed
to take his red-bladed lightsabers but
didn't keep the red blades she used the
force to purify the kyber crystals
inside the hilts removing the dark side
corruption that caused them to bleed red
this process turned the blades white
reflecting Ahsoka status as neither a
Jedi or a Sith but as something else
Ahsoka then modified the hilts to have a
curved shape and a rectangular profile
making them more comfortable for her
reverse grip fighting style she used
these white lightsabers for Many
Adventures including helping Ezra
Bridger and the ghost crew confronting
Darth Vader and searching for Grand
Admiral thrawn these white lightsabers
are a symbol of ahsoka's Independence
balance and courage in the year 4 BBY
Ahsoka joined the ghost crew on a
mission to rescue four sensitive
children from the Empire onto Kobo there
she encountered two inquisitors the
seventh sister and the fifth brother who
were hunting down Jedi survivors and
their allies Ahsoka fought them off and
saved the children along with Kanan
Jairus and Ezra Bridger two Jedi who are
part of the ghost crew she also met a
mysterious Ally who turned out to be
Maul who had escaped from Mandalore and
survived the Clone Wars in three BBY
Ahsoka accompanied Kanan and Ezra to the
lothal Jedi Temple where they sought
guidance from the force there Ahsoka had
a vision of Anakin who blamed her for
leaving him and becoming his enemy she
also learned that Darth Vader was Anakin
and was devastated by the truth she
vowed to find out what had happened to
her former master in two BBY Ahsoka
joined Kanan and Ezra on a mission to
malachor an ancient Sith world that held
secrets of the dark side there they
encountered Maul again were offered to
help them find a way to destroy the Sith
however Maul betrayed them and blinded
Kanan with his lightsaber he also
revealed his true goal to use Ezra as
his apprentice and lure Vader to
malachor Ahsoka faced Vader in a final
confrontation while Kanan and Ezra
escaped with the help of Chopper their
Droid companion Ahsoka Invader fought in
the Sith Temple which was collapsing due
to Ezra's activation of a super weapon
Ahsoka managed to damage Vader's mask
revealing Anakin's face she refused to
leave him behind despite his hatred for
her she was last seen being pulled into
a portal by Ezra who had traveled back
in time through a mystical Dimension
called the world Between Worlds in the
year one BBY Ahsoka was rescued by Ezra
from malachor through the world Between
Worlds she thanked him for saving her
life but told him that he had to return
to his own time and face his Destiny she
also told him that she would find him
when he needed her most she then
returned to malachor where she found
morai a convor bird that was connected
to her through the daughter's life force
she followed Maura into the depths of
the Sith temple in the year 9 ABY Ahsoka
arrived on corvus where she met din
jarin a Mandalorian Bounty Hunter who is
looking for a Jedi to help train grogu a
force sensitive child of Yoda species
Ahsoka agreed to help din in exchange
for information on the location of Grand
Admiral thrawn a former Imperial officer
who had kidnapped Ezra and disappeared
into the unknown regions Ahsoka and din
fought against Morgan ellsbeth the
magistrate who ruled over Caledon a city
on corvus Ahsoka defeated Elizabeth and
learned that thrawn was still alive she
then told Den to take grogu to tython a
Plano where he could reach out to other
Jedi through the force she also revealed
Kroger's named and history to DIN and
gave him a best car spear as a gift
although ahsoka's future is uncertain we
have some ideas about where she'll be
headed in the upcoming Ahsoka series set
to release on August 23 2023 on Disney
plus she's likely still looking for Ezra
Bridger the Jedi who disappeared with
grand Admiral thrawn at the end of Star
Wars Rebels she may have learned
thrawn's location from the Magister on
corvus and begin trying to find him and
Ezra she's also likely preparing for a
confrontation with Ron who may be a
threat to the new Republic or the Jedi
she may have allies or enemies in this
Quest such as Sabine Wren bocatine Crees
and moff Gideon it'll also be
interesting to see as Ahsoka continues
to explore the mysteries of the force
such as the world Between Worlds the
Jedi Temple on tython or grogu's Origins
subscribe for more Star Wars content and
if you liked the video check out the one
on your screen too
[Music]